you read about these guys and you hear
about them at school in re and things
like that backpack you know you'd never
ever believe you had the chance to sit
and eat breakfast with them all right
excellent
morning sir good morning how are you
wait now he's got five skulls on there
I've got four on mine what's the
difference
only the the men did they have dig in
their heads off heads off
no weirdest and he's taking two heads
off in his time yes I don't let me
breakfast before he takes mine off oh
yeah yeah hey cool my laddo nickel
magazine you had to damage my Paulie
no one go home one that she would yeah
yeah yeah shut clap
I don't know Cheryl Helen in the Hat run
for me before before we go for a hunt
yes we were certified chicken strike
tell it three territories now with a
chicken's blood
we'd smear all the guns or what whatever
type of weapon we're taking for a hunt
we do this is the ritual just to be one
with nature like okay okay great why is
it this poorly in testing I check for
them are handling it successful or not
if there's blood on this side see inside
then do they will be injury but there's
no blood today so there's no cycle yeah
tell them all now have you recognize a
blue t-shirt don't [ __ ] shoot okay a
wife and four kids to feed
are you a good shot yeah
you